i'm mike jordan work at machine learning
here and i'm happy to start with stephen
bates
um hey everybody so i'm going to be
talking today about predictive
difference for black box models so
roughly you can think about this as how
do i get confidence intervals on
predictions when i do something like um
run a deep neural network
um so this is joint work with some folks
at stanford um anastasios liberal
jachendra and mike
thanks
sorry i came from stanford berkeley
whoops
uh okay we'll keep going all right so
i'm going to talk a little bit about
predicted infants like i said um the
motivation here is as many people have
noted earlier in earlier sessions
in these um sensitive applications or
say scientific research when i use
something like a deep neural network or
some sort of black box model
the predictions that come out the other
side i need to know something about how
reliable they are i need to know
something you know will they work on a
future input are there error bars on
them and things like that so that's the
setting um for the talk i'm going to
outline some techniques for doing that
okay so a key challenge here when we're
working in this setting is that these
predictive models are very complex so if
you look at something like a
state-of-the-art neural network it might
have you know 60 hundreds of layers
this image gpt a transformer model has
6.8 billion parameters so these models
are really really massive and the
question are the question is you know
how can i work with such an object to
get statistical guarantees
okay um so when i'm working with this
really great
predictive model can i just ignore the
uncertainty that's coming out of these
predictions and the answer i don't think
i need to convince you is absolutely not
um
can i fall back on maybe simpler models
where i do have a richer toolkit for a
predictive or predictive or statistical
inference and the answer is you know no
a lot of times these great complicated
predictive models have the best
prediction accuracy right so if you
really want to squeeze out every ounce
of prediction accuracy you're in an
image task say you're going to want to
use something like
you know image gpt
um so what we're going to do in this
talk is we're going to kind of build a
set of tools that wrap around these
black box models you can think of
something like cross validation it's
kind of a meta procedure that goes on
top
of a black box model
and we're going to use that to get these
statistical guarantees
so the sort of paradigm we're going to
be working in here is we're going to
change the game from returning point
predictions to returning set value
predictions so in a simple
classification task that might look like
this so this is a
classifier trend on imagenet it's a
resnet um and in this particular task
i'm showing you confidence sets that are
going to come out of
of techniques like i'm going to show you
so for example on this image it turns
out it's a pretty easy image um and my
neural network knows that it's a
squirrel so just a squirrel
on a more difficult image like this
center image or this right image you're
going to return sets that are of
non-zero size again it's a confidence
set or a confidence interval
so for example on this moderate image
it's a little bit of a harder image
because the squirrel is
at a weird angle to the camera it has
kind of a slightly strange background
with other distracting objects in it so
in this case the confidence set that's
going to come out of this routine that
i'll show you is fox squirrel gray fox
bucket or rain barrel okay so
my um network in this case is saying i
can't tell you for sure which of these
labels is the correct label but i'm
pretty sure it's one of these okay so
again just we've changed the format here
so
returning point predictions to returning
confidence sets
okay
now it turns out we can do this in a way
that gives you good statistical
guarantees and i'll elaborate on that
throughout the rest of the talk
okay
um so i just showed you a pretty simple
prediction task it was just a
classification test so the right answer
is just one of some finite number of
labels we might want to do something
similar kind of for a whole suite of
machine learning problems and so uh in
this work what we do is we kind of
extend this confidence interval paradigm
to work for a large number of loss
functions or you can think about them as
statistical error rates so for a lot of
different learning problems we can kind
of define these loss functions or
statistical error rates and then we can
derive predictors that work say on top
of the neural net that satisfy
the satisfy these statistical error
rates that control some statistical
error rate okay so what i'm showing you
here is a segmentation example so what
you input to the network is say an image
and what you output what you want it to
output is a
subset of the pixels that corresponds in
this case to a tumor okay so you had
some ground truth data
and then you fit a network on it and you
wanted to output
these sets
what we're going to use as our kind of
notion of statistical error rate in this
particular prediction task
is the false negative rate so i want i
might ask you to give me these kind of
sets of prediction predicted tumors and
you know i might want to kind of certify
that i got 90 of the tumor pixels okay
so this is a false negative rate this is
an example of a
error rate that we can control okay
it turns out we can do this with finite
sample guarantees kind of precise
guarantees i'll show you in a couple
slides it'll work with any predictive
model which is to say we can build it on
top of you know a black box neural
network whatever that happens to be
excuse me
and it will work with any distribution
so you don't need to posit regularity
conditions on the underlying
distribution of say
images of tumors in this case or
colonoscopy images the only kind of
assumption underlying the inference is
that you have some iid sample from a
population okay
and in particular as i said before we're
going to work with sort of a general set
of statistical error rates
okay i should say i'm working in this
kind of general field of conformal
prediction um it started in kind of the
late 90s and it's recently been kind of
revived in statistics and machine
learning and elsewhere
and there's kind of this general set of
tools or at least
a there was a more limited set of tools
that were sort of generalizing in this
talk um to handle this problem
okay so the setting here uh this will be
the heaviest slide with notation don't
worry so the setting here is i start
with some predictive model it could be a
neural network it could be something
else and i'm just going to take it as a
given i'm not going to try to understand
how it's working i'm just going to kind
of feed in inputs and outputs and learn
something about how it's working
but there's no assumptions about
smoothness or whatever that object is
i'm going to take some fresh data that
was not used to train the predictive
model and i'm going to use this to kind
of add one extra layer on top of it so
i'm going to use this to add my
confidence intervals on top of the
neural network for example so add some
fresh data
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
build a family of set valued predictors
i'm going to call these t lambda for
lambda in capital lambda
and they map inputs which live in script
x to outputs which live in 2 to the y
remember i changed the game to return
outputs that now live in kind of the
power set of say the label space with
pixels okay
so you should think about this as kind
of a low dimensional statistical model
in fact it's a one-dimensional
statistical model that i built on top of
my neural network and that's the only
thing i'm going to be manipulating
okay
and then these last two lines here are
kind of introducing notation for
the statistical error control so i have
some loss functions so you give me a
ground truth and a prediction and i
assign some loss to that you know kind
of pair of predictions and ground truth
and i want to control that quantity and
expectation which we'll call the risk
okay so the form of error control that
we can get with this talk is a sort of a
high probability guarantee
so the user is going to choose two
parameters gamma and delta that are
informing what this error control is and
you can train
this family of set value predictors or
you can select
one element from this family of set
value predictors such that it satisfies
the following property
the probability that your risk exceeds
this threshold gamma is less than delta
okay so i picked
i picked a risk threshold gamma in
advance and now i'm promising you that
you don't exceed that too much
okay so if i wanted a false negative
rate that was below 90 i can get that
most of the time unless i see a really
bad training so
okay so just to visualize the risk of t
is a random object because t is going to
be some random function trained on data
it has some distribution it's too
complicated for me to know exactly what
it is however i can promise you that i'm
taking it in such a way that you don't
fall to the right of gamma too
frequently
okay so this is the
notion of error control that we can
achieve and i'll kind of show you how to
do that very briefly on the next couple
slides
um first just to internalize this
definition a bit more what what do we
get in this tumor's example so this is a
a real example there's about 8 000 um
tumors and i ran this simulation
experiment where i select a thousand of
them for training and i use the
remaining for validation
and here's the histogram we see across
the different runs of what is the false
negative rate that we get okay i wanted
a false negative rate of
0.1 and i only wanted to exceed that a
small fraction of the time
and you can see that's exactly what we
get so this point one corresponds to
this vertical line and i don't fall to
the right of it too often okay so unless
i got a little bit unlucky the final
predictor that i return to you satisfies
that notion of air control
and you can see the sets we get in this
example are pretty good and they're
pretty tight around the ground
okay so where's all this coming from
i'll just sketch it very briefly so
let's look at this center panel what you
do is you had this one-dimensional
family of predictors that you built on
top of your neural network
okay it turns out you can build it in
such a way that the risk is monotone in
that parameter so
um the y-axis here is the risk it's like
the error rate that i'm trying to
control the x-axis is this parameter and
i don't see this black curve this black
curve is a ground truth it's only known
to nature but i estimate this ground
truth black curve with some data and
that's what i'm plotting in gold okay so
the gold curve is a upper bound it's a
conservative estimate of the black curve
it's based on data and the property that
it satisfies is it's an upper bound with
probability one minus delta
okay
i'll note that it's only a point wise
upper bound so it's a pretty weak
property i'm not demanding that the
whole curve is an upper bound it's just
a point wise upper bound and so you can
get this from data from various
concentration results including say huff
things inequality or more modern
variants that are um sharper
[Music]
all right okay so this is where it comes
from the procedure is pretty simple you
just look at your upper confidence bound
which again came from some data and then
you stop at your desired risk level
gamma okay
okay so i'll show you one example and
then i'll skip to the end
um
okay i'm going to show you a multi-label
classification task so in this case the
y is a subset of 1 to 80 and i have a
predictor that spits out a
kind of predictive probability for each
of the classes
um my loss again i'm going to use the
false negative rate so i want to return
sets that contain most of the true
classes
okay you can see here what some of the
sets look like and then you can also
verify in simulation experiments that
you are getting that error control that
you asked for
um i won't have time to tell you about
some of these other details you can do
it on complicated tasks like protein
structure prediction okay so um
in summary uh i work on these
predictive inference problems for a lot
of kind of machine learning tasks it
turns out you can get really solid
statistical guarantees even when working
with things like these complex deep
learning models and roughly you should
think about this is i did some low
complexity statistical task on top of
the neural network and i can control
that last step really precisely so
that's how i can get something like
finite sample guarantees and finite
simple confidence
all right
um
thank you all very much
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah absolutely so um
the number of samples you need for the
calibration step is something like 500
to 1000 roughly speaking it will vary
with the task but that's kind of the
order of magnitude you should you should
think of as far as how many samples you
need to train the model that's just
totally
application specific
um
in all the kind of simulation results
that i sketched here the size of the
calibration set was a thousand so there
were a thousand extra points that you
used to train the confidence intervals
all right thank you